hi guys dr. Burke here in this video I
want to talk about a really good remedy
for floaters in the eye now this remedy
is also good for dry eyes as well but
the question is what is floaters it's
those little things that float across
that little black spots that you might
see some people have them some people
don't
but it's basically a breakdown of some
protein tissue in the eyeball itself
that's floating around okay that's what
you're seeing and the remedy is liquid
MFM okay you can find this anywhere I'm
not going to give any brand names
because I'm not endorsing any products
but you could find it it's in a liquid
and it stands for methylsulfonylmethane
okay now MSM has been known to actually
be good for joint lubrication in your
joints skin hair nails it's an organic
sulfur so it's a great detox for your
liver people don't realize how powerful
this is to hydrate the eye to clean the
eye to reduce inflammation in general or
from seasonal allergies that you might
have that are irritated in the eye but
so many people have dry eye this is what
they need to take to counter that it
actually has a capacity of to soften the
eye itself to make the membrane very
elastic and soft and young again and
provide nutrition that goes right inside
that eye so highly recommend that you
try this if you have these problems and
then give us your feedback below so
thanks for watching hey thanks so much
for watching
press the subscribe button and I'm going
to hold on one second who is this oh no
one's okay honey listen I'm right in the
middle of filming here she wants to say
hi okay I said hi I got to go okay but
so if you like the videos press
subscribe and I will keep you updated
with the future event